Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And
just checking in on you.
Yeah.
Just checking in on you.
However the fuck I used to do it.
Uh,
my warrior,
I am in Winnipeg,
Canada.
I didn't bring all my recording equipment,
so I got to figure the level here that I can talk close to this thing without
fucking up yours.
I'm in Winnipeg,
Canada.
And guess what?
It's still cold.
It's May 18th and it's like 42 degrees out,
which is,
it's annoying.
Why does it keep making that noise?
I'm not getting any closer to him.
Oh,
it's the wind.
Ah,
I see.
Keep it steady.
I just rested on my chest.
Well that work.
How's that?
Okay,
good.
Anyways,
it's like 43 fucking degrees out,
you know,
which isn't cold for the wintertime,
but for me it's fucking annoying.
You know?
And I didn't dress properly.
I came up here with a win fucking break.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
just walking around,
having a zip up,
my God damn coach or noise.
Oh Bill,
fuck you.
Everything and noise.
You.
Well,
maybe you're right.
Maybe it does.
Um,
I don't know what I'm just,
I'm just gonna hold this fucking record.
Um,
I'll tell you,
you know what's fucking overrated by the way?
Breakfast,
potatoes,
breakfast potatoes,
Cole slaw,
beans and rice.
All right?
All of them just taken up a fucking chair on the bench that someone else who
wants to get in the fucking game could be,
you know,
you just
dump all,
like the like just rebuild,
start over again.
Like the fucking capitals,
you know,
play fillers,
that's all it is.
Fuck.
Breakfast potatoes,
they never taste good and they just make you fat and you feel like you got to
eat them because your mother was always like,
well,
if you don't fucking finish that,
you're going to sit there until the morning.
And he just sat there,
right?
Watching the ketchup dry,
um,
turned in that it actually starts,
you know,
coagulating Cetera.
Is that the right word?
Um,
anyways,
I don't understand why this fucking record is going to have to be like this,
making all this racket.
So I'm trying to be a grump here.
Um,
so I'm in Winnepeg tonight for two,
two shows.
Um,
and then I go up to Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan,
scas,
right.
Um,
also known as the Paris of the prairies,
which to me is the greatest fucking nickname of a city than I can.
What do you,
what do you want again?
The big apple that stinks.
Beantown horrific.
The Berg.
Terrible.
Does la even have a nickname?
Trying to think of yellow ones.
The land.
Cleveland.
Ugh.
That whole fucking thing where all of a sudden every goddamn city needed,
I know you always talk about this,
but I'll never get over that.
The awful low,
is that what they called Buffalo?
The Paris of the prairie's.
How great is that?
You know what I mean?
See e you're going out there.
It's,
the prayer is it's going to be a little mom and pop type of shit,
but it's going to be beautiful.
I'm going there and then we go down to Regina afterwards,
which I believe,
yeah.
What's the nickname?
Watch city.
Is that what it is?
Something like that or was that the Golden State Warriors?
I Dunno.
Speaking of which I s the only way you can root for the Golden State Warriors is
if you bet on them or if you're from the Golden State,
Oakland,
you know,
area and you're already a fan of Jesus Christ.
It was already bad enough to rent piled on there and killed the OKC golden state
rivalry,
which is what we be watching right now.
Okay?
Instead,
you're literally listening to announcements like last night when the Celtics
were playing,
Reggie Miller is like going because they're trying to sell this series going
like,
oh,
you know,
the only one book pen.
I mean,
some of them was good.
Would you tell him point at Reggie Miller goes,
goes,
look,
we both know there's two meteors head that one another and we're just gonna
Watch him collide.
So I'm trying to do the last time I watched the eastern and Western conference
finals and they felt like the first round of the playoffs.
I'm fucking warriors.
Oh my God,
they're filthy.
Filthy.
I love Popovich.
Going off on that fucking goof,
how many slides,
steps did he fucking take?
Okay.
To make sure his foot was going to be in the vicinity of where Leonard was going
to land.
And for somebody out there who doesn't think that that's filthy,
give me a fucking break.
Give me a break.
He's taking a shot.
You know,
why did he have to take that last little slide step,
skip,
and then just have his fucking foot right there.
It'd be one thing if they couldn't do like an entire highlight reel of him not
only being a dirty bastard,
but actually trying to fucking whatever pop,
what's his face as Leonard shoulder out or whatever the hell he was doing that
time when he dragged them down to the ground.
He's a piece of shit.
And the only thing worse than that fucking move that he made was that awful
little dead three skip and a hop thing that he did afterwards as he was holding
onto his head.
Like he couldn't fucking believe it.
Um,
well listen,
what the fuck do I know about who?
But I know Popovich knows a lot about hoop and I know he's gone through a lot of
shit and he's gone through a lot of playoff series.
I ain't never seen him go off like that,
so I'm going to go with what he said as opposed to when I was watching ESPN and
the fucking sports anchor,
it goes to Steven A.
Smith.
Hey Steven.
You know,
we've both played the game a,
do you think
it is fucking anchor sitting there?
You know,
he's going to question Popovich and Steven,
a Smith who I love was just like,
he basically said,
what I'm saying with Popovich says,
it's true then.
Yeah,
you kinda got to go with that.
But,
um,
the biggest fucking story and hoop had already came and went because the fucking
Cavaliers series with the Celtics already started and they fucking kicked our
ass.
Um,
was I owe a certain member of the Boston Celtics a big apology.
Okay.
All of this time doubting him,
you know,
making fun of his choice of sneakers,
making fun of the way he looked in those sneakers,
talking about how many times he was on the wrong side of the poster.
Kelly.
Oh,
fucking LAENNEC.
Yeah.
What happened?
Okay.
The man simply took over the game in a fourth quarter of a game.
Seven for the Boston Celtics wearing in the green and white
shades of,
of Cedric Maxwell.
But one game we say,
just get on my back cause I'm fucking taking this thing home.
And that's exactly what he did.
Guys scored 14 points in the,
uh,
the fourth quarter
he took Isaiah is Thomas his watch off and put it on his own fucking wrist and
I'll put down the court.
He went,
he was back in guys down.
He was fucking dunk.
Eddie was layups.
He was hitting trees.
It's unfucking believable.
Now having said that,
he did it once.
So game one of the cavalier series,
he was right back to the Kelly Olynyk that we know.
You know,
I think that was a very special episode.
You know how they used to do that with Sitcoms,
a very special episode.
They would always take on like pregnancy,
abortion,
uh,
racism or something like that.
And then they would go right back to being in an all white show.
You know,
that's how white people cared in the 80s.
That's how we did it.
We didn't have to do anymore than that.
That's all that there was.
Um,
so whenever I Kelly Olynyk Jesus Christ,
so I guess he's not going to do shit in this series until it,
unless we get it to game seven.
Um,
Celtics got the number one pick.
I mean,
it's just all,
that's all we got.
All we got to do now is just wait until Lebron gets old.
And uh,
I actually hate the fucking warriors so much that I don't care if they,
if,
if the fucking Cavaliers sweep the Celtics
because I want them nice and rested when they play those fucking dark bags out
there.
Who's that other guy that got on the team where he g e you go to garden and he
jumps up to take a jump shot and he kicked you in the balls.
He's kicked like half the league and the balls.
I'm going to buy a half the league.
I mean like three or four different guys.
After a while it's like dude that she move.
I love ESPN.
Went to him to ask them if they thought that fucking that fucking Nazi Guard
House fucking guy that got there.
You know,
asked him if he thought he was dirty.
The Guy who accidentally kicks people in the balls.
Do you think his teammates dirty?
Yeah.
Well what would you rather have?
Would you have that but twisted ankle or rub you fucking balls separated for the
next nine years?
Um,
anyways,
I don't know why.
I don't know why Chris Paul couldn't go to the Lakers,
but Kevin Duran could go to the,
to the fucking
the warriors and now that,
now that the worries are filthy,
your shit,
they took Leonard out of the series.
It's just,
it's a joke.
I would rather watch the real housewives than the western conference finals in
the NBA.
Um,
so anyways,
enough about that shit.
MMM.
Type in my password here,
dude.
What the fuck's going on with the Ottawa senators?
When are they going to start behaving like the Ottawa senators?
I don't get what's going on here.
You know,
I still think the penguins are going to beat him every time.
Like the penguins get the fucking shit kicked out of.
And then what happens?
They come back,
they give you the old right there,
Fred.
And they fucking,
when the,
uh,
they,
when the series,
um,
I still think that they're going to take the whole thing.
MMM.
Now here's something I wanted to talk to you guys about.
My,
I just flew up here to fucking Winnipeg and I don't know what happened,
but the fucking level of animal that was on my flight to this guy next to me,
you know,
I told you I've right up front,
I even call it first class.
It's just human class.
They treat you like a human being.
That's all that happens up front.
If you ever wanted,
they don't s smash you all on the back and all that shit,
right?
So I'm waiting to get on,
So they had people with wheelchairs,
they get on first and you know,
fucking people with kids.
If you're in the military,
you know,
if you're wearing a red shirt,
they've got like a bunch of things,
right?
So people were sitting in first class to getting all huffy going wins first
class going to board,
right?
You know that white guy with the loafers and no socks,
like dead fucking energy,
right?
So we're going to get on in this fucking fat fuck,
you know,
in his twenties just completely blown out.
Body,
big giant fat boys.
I'm a polywood producer,
fucking glass,
his stupid hat wearing sweatpants and some big comfy fucking shirt,
you know,
just giving into the fact that's why he's fat.
All these fat people that wear comfortable clothes,
you're going to be fat forever cause you,
cause you never,
you're not uncomfortable.
You got to keep the clothes that you had when you were that way.
You don't go to the fucking dry cleaner or go to the God Damn Nike store and buy
yourself a giant fucking sleeping bag with drawstrings on it.
Cause you're never gonna really feel how fat you are until you go to get on a
fucking airplane.
Right.
So I'm the,
so this guy is trying to cut the fucking line,
right.
And uh,
you know,
I sold a box him out.
Yeah.
And uh,
they scanned my thing and I get a call to get on the flight and this fucking fat
fuck comes down the thing.
And he literally,
he gets on the plane,
he goes,
where am I sitting up front?
Like really?
Like,
like weird.
Like you can't just look gates and lady like it looks at the ticket and he's
fucking sitting right next to me.
So I'm putting my shit in the overhead compartment.
It's go shoes with a fucking caused the brush right by me.
I said,
hey buddy,
I go watch out from my bag.
He's like,
oh,
sorry.
He kind of backed back out again.
You know,
he wasn't gonna hit my bag.
I just didn't like how he fucking brushed right by me.
Right.
So he sits down,
right.
Giant fucking snowman looking Douche bag right.
Sits down and he's so fat.
I'm in first class,
he's still spilling into my seat fucking elbow in me and all that stuff is shit.
Just like,
this is not what I'm spending my sky miles on,
you know.
So,
um,
the lady,
the stewardess comes over,
she goes,
you know frank,
get you guys something to drink,
right?
I order a drink and the guy goes,
can I have a blanket?
They go,
she goes,
yes.
So when she comes up with a blanket,
she holds it out to him.
He just fucking rips it out of her hand and was like opened it up.
And just the way he was so choppy and like aggressive yet couldn't find his
seat.
I was like,
this guy,
I don't know what this is.
I don't know what the fuck this,
this,
this guy on drugs.
Is He autistic?
Is it Asperger?
I don't fucking know cause I don't really know what the symptoms of any of that
shit is.
You know,
I saw the rain man and uh,
you know,
I don't know what else I fucking went our podcasts the one time with somebody.
That aspect,
I can't fucking tell him.
You just don't know that they act a little off.
All right.
And I'm not going to be yet another douche bag who doesn't have a psychology
degree,
let alone practicing that profession to start analyzing someone's mental
situation.
So then he fucking sits there.
Okay.
He rips that the blanket open cause somehow this tub of shit is going to give
fucking cold.
And uh,
he starts doing the,
uh,
what's that thing when the restless leg syndrome except his leg weighs as much
as my entire body.
So it's like actually shaking the plane and uh,
fortunately it was a red eye and my God,
you know,
let this fucking guy just go to sleep.
But then is he going to have sleep apnea?
I don't know what,
long story short,
we finally ended up,
I connected in Minneapolis.
Okay.
And when I got up,
I deliberately stood in a way where he couldn't get out of his seat cause I knew
he was going to brush by me.
Once again,
it'd be fucking rude.
Whatever the fuck his deal is.
So I passive aggressively stand there.
So I get off the plan,
my grade,
I don't have to fucking deal with this guy anymore.
Right.
So I get off the plane and as I'm standing there trying to figure out where my
connecting flight gate is,
this fucking jerk off comes walking off the plane and he's still wearing the
blanket.
He's got it wrapped around them.
Oh by the way it was so,
so of course wearing sandals,
you know,
like all animals do.
They just,
they have to have their feet out.
You know,
like animals,
animals are all barefoot,
they don't have shoes.
Right.
So these guys have sandals cause they're half an animal.
Like,
you know what I mean?
If you're in a hot climate or you fucking at the beach or whatever,
going down to the pool,
the spa that low,
that sandals.
Anyways,
so
he comes walking off the plane and then just walks up to the,
you know,
those,
those little fucking cars that they drive fat people around,
an old people,
blind people and stuff,
you know.
And uh,
he walks up to one of those guys to go,
excuse me sir.
He goes,
what do I do for the next five hours?
Why wait for my flight and that.
So I was like,
all right,
this guy's,
this guy's fucked up.
And the guy's like,
ah,
I as a food court.
So then he walks up to the ticket lady now just standing there watching him
because I got enough time cause now it's entertaining.
Watching him meet people and watching them doing the math on their face,
you know,
is this,
you see it on their face like,
what the fuck am I dealing with?
So he talks to the ticket agent,
freaks her out,
then comes walking back and he walks up to the car and he just goes,
he goes,
sir,
where are you taking me?
And you pop psychologist.
The guy finally just goes,
there's a food court down.
Then they just wandered off,
still wearing the blanket.
Now my buddy that I'm working with this week,
he was trying to say that he thought the guy was on pills.
I have no idea what the fuck it was,
but uh,
it was hilarious.
But anyway,
so the level of fucking animal,
so that guy was there.
There was another guy on my flight,
he was wearing Pajama Pot,
Pajama bottoms,
and he had a neck,
neck,
pillow.
I mean,
I didn't even know where to go from there.
There was another guy who had the worst hat I've ever seen and he was carrying a
hard shell case for the hat.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
maybe that was his good hat and he was wearing his bad hat on the flight.
I Dunno.
It's like,
wait,
what are you running for president in 1905 and some shit.
Like you're riding on a tweet.
It was a fucking hatbox.
We're kind of a man as a hatbox.
It was a solid plastic one,
like,
like a snare drum case.
But as for a fucking hat,
um,
so for whatever reason I get here to the hotel and I'm reading about this plane
Crash Air Canada flight six 24,
they say the timeline of the crash,
right?
10 Oh five,
the plane leaves 10 56 Air Canada tells flight crew,
uh,
than an Air Canada flight.
It had landed on Halifax runway oh five after a missed approach due to
insufficient visibility because of weather conditions,
controller tells the crew to hold at 9,000 feet.
Blahblahblahblah Blah,
blah,
blah.
Right?
The fucking crew asked to confirm to delights Iran setting five controllers,
sets that are on four,
they'll eventually be on five.
They remain on for long story short,
this fucking guy flying this thing,
he ends up hitting like a snow bank.
Some lights,
he's fucking hidden shit off the plane.
They go slide down the runway and they come to a stop.
Says aircraft comes to a rest about 1900 feet beyond the threshold.
Okay?
This is like how scary this was.
Um,
captain disconnects the autopilot and plane makes automated calls.
There are a hundred and then 50 feet above the land.
Cope copilot says to pull up,
uh,
the AC,
the Air Canada's six 24 Sevres and electric power line.
Cutting power to the airport.
Terminal captain advances thrust levers to the takeoff goal round and pulls
side.
Stick to the full nose up position.
A left main tire hits and approach like 861 feet from the runway threshold.
The main landing gear after lower fuselage and left engine cowling strike the
snow covered ground on an embankment sloping towards the runway.
The plane strikes the localizer and Tena um,
and continues airborne before striking the ground twice more and sliding along
the runway says what people are dealing with.
You guys ever see that Louis C K episode where they were coming in for landing
and everyone was screaming bloody murder.
That's what I picture.
And I pictured Louis on this flight for whatever reason.
Um,
aircraft comes to a rest 1900 feet beyond the threshold is completely lost.
Power Tower control acts activates crash alarm as passages complete evacuation
firefighters arrived at the accident site.
Now listen to this,
listen to this.
This is at 1236 when the firefighters show up.
This is what they see when the passengers are out on the runway.
Now this was a fucking snowstorm that they flew into passengers.
Many wearing open toed shoes,
shorts and tee shirts and carrying baggage is baggage are grouped about 200
meters behind the aircraft and frigid temperatures.
Occupants with more severe injuries sit in the emergency vehicles.
I mean,
kind of a fucking asshole gets on a god the of flight in the middle of a snow
storm wearing open toed fucking shoes,
sandals,
shorts.
You know,
next time I get on a flight and I see those people getting on,
I'll,
I'm going to be thinking as we go down in the fucking Himalayas,
he's going to be the first people to get eaten,
you know?
Or are they going to be the first people that you're going to have to kill
because they're going to be fighting you for your fucking shoes.
MMM.
I don't even know what the point of all of that was.
All I'm just saying,
it's just the level of animal that is at the fucking airport.
And you know what's funny too,
like it's just a way,
when you're walking through an airport,
you can't really see,
you don't really see it.
You know,
like the demographic that you're in,
you don't see it until you get to your gate.
Like
I didn't get the level of animal that was going to fucking Winnipeg until I got
to the gate that was flying to Winnipeg because it's like,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
it's like a,
it's like a mixed drink.
He can't taste the fucking alcohol.
Right.
But then when you get to the gate,
when you get to your gate,
wherever the fuck you going,
barring a few tourists too,
we're just going to visit.
That is a straight shot of what the fuck you're,
you're about ready to walk into
Pajama bottoms with a neck pillow.
MMM.
It's like,
whenever I'm in New York and I'm going to La,
it's like you look at the ear at the airports,
like these people all look like New Yorkers and then all of a sudden you get to
the gate that's going to La and you see the chick with the botox.
You know,
you see the guy with the fake Tan,
he starts seeing the god of your way of dressing.
It's like,
all right,
these la people,
you know,
and then all of a sudden when you get off in la,
they totally blend in with people at the fucking airport.
I Dunno,
I always found that interesting.
Well,
good bill because we did,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry.
Hang on a second.
Let me,
let me read some advertising here for this week and uh,
yeah.
Oh by the way,
then I,
I don't know,
am I going to talk about this first before I go into the advertising?
What's better?
I'll come out of it and talk about it.
All right.
Lift everybody.
L Y,
F,
t.
Uh,
when you drive for the right ride sharing app,
every trip can feel like a walk in the park.
With Lyft,
you can pick your own hours and work when you want.
Lift can make driving the best job in the world.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating Pete.
It's people better.
Lift believes that p being a ride sharing drivers should be fun if you're having
a good time.
So are the passengers.
If you're choosing a ride sharing company to drive,
sorry,
it's to drive for.
Go with the company that treats you better.
Lift.
This is all shade right here.
Lift being all shady.
With Uber,
a Lyft offers inap tipping.
When you drive for lip lift,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers had been paid over $150 million in tip since the feature was introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly.
Instead of waiting for weeks live tizzies and taking the guesswork out of
pickups.
The new app,
the new amp device uses color coding to help passages find their driving's
drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week.
Plus tips.
Want to make more money,
drive more.
It's been never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers being happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating.
So join the ride sharing company that believes in treating people better.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus $500 new
driver bonus.
That's lyft.com l y f t.com.
Limited time only terms apply.
Oh good.
There's only two.
Oh,
this is great movement.
You guys know movement.
Do you?
I Dunno,
they three reinvented the watch business by selling direct to you with over 101
million watches sold today.
I just can't fucking read today.
While they did it again,
except this time was sunglasses and they're going to start selling amber vision.
Oh my God,
everything is so much crisper and clearer.
Uh,
they were tired of having to pay for cheaply,
made throwaway shades or overpriced designer sunglasses.
So they said,
fuck it.
We'll make our own starting at just 70 bucks.
Uh,
talk about your personal experience with the new pair of sunglasses,
which pair you have,
how they look slash feel,
what you enjoy most about it,
how people ask you about it.
What do you want to know,
where you purchased and how much does it cost?
All right.
None of that happened.
I even know you,
I,
this is the first I'm hearing you guys make sunglasses.
So none of that happened,
but it does seem to get a lot of attention out there on the streets if you start
wearing them.
Um,
so be careful.
If you're not looking for attention,
I wouldn't get these fucking sunglasses.
That's incredible.
You don't have anything that I have would have happened if I got them.
You know,
people would want to know about it.
Hey Man,
what'd you get?
Those glasses?
No,
I want to know about those glasses.
Where'd you buy?
What did you purchase them?
How much they cost?
Talk about em.
Talk about movement.
Ver varied selection and styles of finding the perfect pair is risk free with
free shipping and free returns.
All right?
Evidently they have a selection of sunglasses and a,
you pick one that looks the best and you stupid head and uh,
you know,
there's no risk in that.
No one's going to be watching you as you do it.
Okay?
Oh boy.
Moving sunglasses started just $70 with the option to upgrade to polarized.
Oh,
is that when no one can see your eyes?
Is that what you're polarized?
You're like a riverboat gambling.
Then write those overpriced designer brands will run you up to $200.
These are high quality premium,
okay?
Acetate frames,
a,
c,
e,
t,
a t,
no cheap plastic here.
You got to have these.
They have lots of styles to choose from.
Classy,
trendy,
round aviator Marin,
polarized for him or her.
Okay.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Call to action.
Parenthesis must read.
Get 50% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to
movement.com/burr.
You know,
Movement for how they revolutionized the watch industry.
Now's the time to check out their sunglasses.
Go to a movement,
watches.com M v m t.com/burr join the goddamn movement.
Wow.
Like I said,
I hate doing fucking podcast on days that I travel.
MMM.
What am I up to here?
All right,
let's talk about it.
Everybody.
Um,
rest in peace.
Chris Cornell.
Holy Shit.
Unbelievable man.
Unbelievable.
One of the best fucking singers in rock history.
And um,
I hope what they're saying,
I mean,
I guess if you die you die.
But I just,
I dunno,
I hope they're not going to do all a whole bunch of,
okay.
You know how they do that?
They got to kill you again after you die.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking band.
What a,
what an artist,
what are just did their music?
Just
the holds up.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of music that I listened to when I went back,
you know,
and the shit that I used to listen to,
I as a kid was like,
oh my God,
this is horrible.
This is the second Barisone.
I still listened to it because of the,
you know,
it reminds me of a time in my life when I come up to the red light,
I got to turn it down.
Nothing Chris Cornell over did.
Did you have to turn down?
You could,
you could fucking have it cranked and never be embarrassed.
I'm such a huge,
huge fucking loss.
And once again,
someone I should have gone to see,
never did too busy doing this comedy fucking thing.
I was going to go see temple of the dog and I had some other show I couldn't go.
I think Dean del Ray had tickets to that.
He was like,
dude,
it was fucking unbelievable.
And um,
yeah,
it's just fucking awful.
Just off.
I was a huge fan of that band.
And uh,
so now what happens?
I know they're in the middle of a tour,
you know,
you know what they do now is they just find some fucking guy on,
on the Internet that does like an impression of them and then all of a sudden
the guy has to fucking go up there and be like a rock star.
Like,
I,
I've never seen a band like that.
I've never gone to see a band like that,
although I heard the guy from Alison chains fucking murders it.
So who knows?
Um,
I dunno,
I didn't get out of this.
See,
I just,
why I fucking hate talking about sad shit like that.
MMM.
Somewhere in all of that,
I saw a fucking way out of this and now I,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
So anyways,
uh,
plowing ahead,
just fucking plowing ahead.
He,
oh,
I know it was to say,
you know what,
I went back and I downloaded skid row's slave to the grind
and that album,
that album marked the end of my musical youth,
that album came out in like the summer of [inaudible] 91 and then in September
fucking,
you know,
all of a sudden Nirvana's album came out and then that was just,
it,
all of my band's got wiped.
They'll fuck off a MTV,
you know?
And,
um,
okay.
So I went back and I downloaded a slave to the grind monkey business and all
that,
which then maybe go watch,
uh,
you know,
a bunch of skid row fucking videos and there's a video man,
Aye,
you got to see this shit.
It's from 1991,
I believe.
91 and 92,
it's skid row on SNL and Sebastian Bach in the whole band,
just fucking murdering
monkey business.
And
I dunno,
to me that was like for me,
I just feel like I'm doing it now.
I've said it so much that I actually say for me now,
I say for me and to me because I keep doing it.
It's like when,
I mean they used to make fun of this guy.
He said,
yeah,
you liked it,
that you liked it,
did that.
And I still,
I kept and we just kept doing it to each other.
And I was in a meeting when pitching his show and I was talking about a comic
that I liked and I said,
yeah,
I saw his special.
Yeah,
I liked it.
I,
and I went,
oh my God.
And it was actually liked it.
And we started going like,
they did it to make it even more ridiculous.
And I literally said liked it,
did it.
And I saw the person's face like,
look at me like,
like,
does he have a stutter?
I can't put this guy on fucking camera.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm watching this fucking video and it was the end of like,
aggressive,
fun
fucking bands.
Like they would just fucking killing it.
Just it,
they will like rock stars.
And they were enjoying it before the grunge came in and everyone saying,
God,
I wish I was like,
you,
you muse.
I always hated that fucking line.
So you don't fucking know me.
You condescending cunt.
I'm not easily amused.
I don't find what the fuck you trying to suggest about me even remotely a music.
Can somebody please make a video of that Kurt Cobain singing that line and then
you cut the joke.
Peshy so what?
I'm like a clown.
I like,
I amuse you.
MMM.
Anyways,
yeah.
And then all the sad guys came in.
Kurt Cobain fucking uh,
uh,
who's the Pearl Jam Guy,
Eddie vetter,
that fucking interview that Kurt Loder does with them and he's literally like,
he looks like superman sitting next to fucking Kryptonite.
Like that's how much he's like folded over himself.
Like he didn't want to answer any of the questions.
Like it was literally making a physical reaction to somebody asks him questions
like,
Hey man,
you're selling a bunch of albums that's got to feel good.
Right?
And he was like,
Hey,
it is,
I don't even know how to fucking,
you know what I mean?
I'm sitting here like the fucking posture of Fiona Apple.
They were a bunch of fragile people,
but in the middle of all of that,
in the middle,
all of that was fucking Chris Cornell still belting it out like a fucking,
I dunno,
my version of what a rock star is,
didn't go out there wearing a granny sweater trying to act like he was somebody
in the crowd.
It's like,
no,
you're better than me.
Be better than me.
I don't want to see me up there
be a fucking God.
MMM.
I don't know.
And I just thought Chris Cornell had the goods when it came to that and uh,
it made me go,
I dunno,
I just been listed to a lot of music right around that,
that era.
And I've always known it.
I make fun of Nirvana.
I know they're a great band and shit.
I know they are.
I just,
it's just fun.
They're fun to make fun of because everyone's always like,
and when that album came out,
I knew that music,
as I knew it had now changed,
which is complete horseshit.
There was a few people that knew,
most of us didn't like,
who is this new band?
And then all of a sudden it was his other new band and it was just like all of a
sudden MTV decided that they were going to just like,
this was the new shit and they just started spooning it into our mouths and we
fucking hate it.
I mean,
that's basically what happened.
I was more than willing
to watch all those same bands I had been listening to keep,
continue to put out albums.
I didn't have a fucking problem.
You know what it was MTV was done with me.
And uh,
that was the first time I really felt dealt.
I was 23 years old and I was just like,
yeah,
that's,
they don't,
I'm done as far in their head.
I'm already married with two fucking kids and they can't squeeze a dime out of
my pockets,
so fuck this guy.
Right.
And then it was smashing Pumpkins,
you know,
I dunno.
But Soundgarden was always one where I didn't have to make the leap of like,
okay,
this is this new shit.
I just kind of sounds a little different.
Like I absolutely fucking love that band.
Love all the odd time stuff.
I love all of that shit.
And it's just a fucking shame.
It's a fucking shame.
But you know something,
if you want to watch something uplifting,
I'm going to post.
Um,
skid row was Sebastian Bach,
absolutely fucking murdering monkey business.
And,
uh,
I love to,
in the end when he,
he'd after you've just fucking destroys one of the greatest live voices
underrated of all fucking time.
Then he was like,
funny.
In the end I have to like doing those high fucking heavy metals screams all the
way down to the growl and then at the end he's just like,
oh,
thank you very much.
Just like he still thinks it's weird voice.
Uh,
it was awesome.
So anyways,
rest in peace,
Chris Carr now and um,
I dunno,
I dunno what else to say.
I'm so fucking sick of having to say that,
but I guess that's a part of getting old.
Um,
which is something I have to actually talk to you about that talk to you guys
about that,
you know,
like that thing where you just want to be out to live to be a hundred.
It's like part of living to be 100 is you're going to bury all your friends,
you know,
and you should really start looking at your friends and if you're remotely
taking care of yourself,
you,
you know,
which ones are going to go.
I hate to say it,
but you do that fucking guy eating the burgers and the fries and the fucking
just putting on another 10 every year.
Every year the Christmas sweater gets a little bit bigger.
Right.
Okay.
Until next day you're wandering around ordering people around,
wearing the fucking airplane blanket through the fucking terminal area.
Yeah.
Like that guy,
that guy I saw,
that guy's not going to be around a lot.
It's not gonna be around long.
You know what I mean?
I think that restless leg syndrome that he had going on,
that was his heart screaming for help.
You know,
I've given them enough chest pains.
He's not listening to me.
Can Somebody for the love of God slap the fuck twinkie out of this guy's mouth
up,
Jesus.
But why do you gotta be me?
All right.
So anyways,
I got Winnepeg tonight,
then Saskatoon,
the Paris of the prairies,
and then I got fucking,
uh,
Regina and I will not do one vagina joke.
I did one of the podcasts,
just cause you know you got to one to watch city,
you have rip city,
you got the twin city and you got to watch city and that's it.
So now
this is going to be some nerdy shit.
This isn't even the podcast right now.
Here we go.
Hang on one second.
Let me get a fucking map of Canada map of Canada.
Uh,
uh Oh.
Did I ever give the Edmonton fans a shut off the singing the national anthem.
Oh,
come on.
Why does it always go to Wikipedia?
Now
I don't need to know what a map of Kennedy is.
I need to fucking see one map of Canada,
a home and native land.
Cool.
Hate
on us horns,
carb man.
Right here we go visit page.
Now I've got to go to the page
and now I've got to try and make the fucking map bigger.
I want to see a map of Canada.
Yeah.
As I said.
All right.
Yeah,
I have been to with this fucking trip.
As far as the southern portion,
I think I've been to every major city.
I got Vancouver,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
Saskatoon,
Regina,
Winnipeg,
Toronto,
Ottawa,
Montreal.
Then I've been to like Monkton.
I Bet I went to the maritimes.
I came in with a fuck.
I went something in Nova Scotia,
New Brunswick.
I know I went to New Brunswick,
maybe not Nova Scotia.
Um,
I dunno.
I've been to fucking hammered town.
I've been to London,
Ontario.
Okay.
I mean,
I think Yellowknife is next.
That's where I got to go next.
I should,
I is all starting Alaska.
I'll do something in the Yukon territory with those.
Fuck him in that place up there.
I can't see.
It's all blurry,
so same Whitesnake.
Is that where the bands from?
I don't know.
I'll put it together,
but this is,
I'm not going to stop,
man.
This was the last province that I needed to go on the southern southern
hemisphere.
What the fuck is it called?
Saskatchewan.
Yeah,
it's Saskatoon in my head.
All right.
That was complete filler.
I don't know why.
Just did that.
That was your breakfast potatoes here on the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
All right.
We're going to play a little music here.
Obviously we can do some sound garden and then you can listen to some,
uh,
another half hour of some greatest hits from a Thursday gone by and another time
or a podcast on Monday.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
I will.
You guys have a great weekend.
You can't and I will talk to you on Monday and once again,
a rested pieces of great Christmas.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's up?
It's the Monday morning podcast.
Hey,
what's going on with this bill for the Monday morning podcast and this is the
third attempt at trying to be even remotely and musing on the thing.
It was like the sixth time I've tried to start doing this podcast,
but what's going on?
It's still doing the Monday morning podcast if you want to please every God damn
week,
every week,
every Monday,
and let this,
uh,
Christmas with some shit.
I don't want to take the day off.
All right.
And I worked for myself.
Why decide it's a bill barr?
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is still going on.
It's still birth?
Yeah.
Isn't that exciting?
Every Monday?
I do a fucking podcast.
All right,
what do you want from me?
You know,
hey,
what's going on?
She's still birth and a,
this is not the Monday morning podcast.
Hey,
what's up man?
It's still dry and it is the Monday morning podcast and I'm going to be
multitasking this week.
Hey,
what's going on?
It is a burn and this is the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
welcome.
Welcome.
If you're new to it.
I do one of these every single Monday.
I answer questions.
People email me quick.
Is that bucket add thorough people send me in there a underrated overrated list.
Things that they feel are underrated,
things that they feel are overrated.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is so far and this is uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the official one.
You see?
You see,
that's what I was trying to do last week.
That's what I was trying to do.
I was trying to slip in the MP three of the week there.
That's what I was trying to do there.
Did you enjoy it?
Was it a little bit long?
Did my edits sock?
I'm sure it did.
And I'm,
I'll get emails from people because that's what the web is really all about.
It's not about connecting with other people.
It's about having the ability to tell somebody that they fucking suck when
they're just sitting there in their underwear,
eating a bowl of fucking week checks.
You know?
That's how my day starts.
Every fucking day.
Every day I get up and,
uh,
well I take my dog for a walk now,
which is fucking awesome.
I do that.
But then,
uh,
wait a minute,
don't I?
I probably do go on my space first.
That's how pathetic I am.
It's how pathetic I am.
I will literally get on my space and a,
I checked out a couple emails,
a couple of comments on whatever shows I've done something.
You saw me on some fucking picture I put up and there's always somebody breaking
my balls over there.
And uh,
that's what the Internet is.
That's what the Internet is.
It's a bunch of punks being able to heckle people without being able to get
trashed back,
you know?
But I'm guilty of it too.
So what the fuck am I going to do?
All right.
It's bill bird,
some Monday morning podcast.
If you didn't know that from the beginning.
Uh,
the opening there,
that's a new thing I'm going to try to be doing is a MP3 the week.
I don't know if I want to do it every week cause I really,
you know,
I already deal with all the questions you guys send me,
which really crow clogs up my email folders and uh,
but you know,
every once in a while,
so you know,
if you've got a cool idea,
send it in.
If it's something I can use on the podcast,
I'll definitely do it.
But I got them in,
I'm kinda nervous about getting a fucking,
uh,
a virus,
you know,
listening to all that audio,
you're not supposed to open shit,
so I don't wanna I don't want to do that,
you know,
so I don't even know what I just fucking told you there.
And I'm sure there's people out there right now.
Oh,
you were Bulger.
Novaris opening an audio but not somebody g-mail.
Are you that fucking stupid?
That's another thing I like about the Internet is when you've just asked people
for fucking help that nobody can,
you know,
some people can help you up,
but so many people on the internet,
their way of helping you out is to give you information while calling you a
fucking moron,
which is why this week on the Monday morning part podcast,
if you are fans of this,
you know that I have douche bag of the week,
but there was so many douche bags this week.
I almost have to,
I,
I almost was like con to the week.
I almost had to bump it up,
you know what I mean?
But I stopped short of that out of respect for some of the female listeners out
there.
So I'm going with Douche bags of the week.
That's plural.
All right,
this is it.
It's the last week,
if you,
if you listened.
I did get a dog and a,
I've never had a dog before and I was having issues because,
uh,
whatever,
listen to last week's podcast,
I don't have time to fucking get into it,
but we had a specialist come over here to find out what the dog's problem was.
And evidently it has separation anxiety because,
um,
it's a perfect fucking dog.
It doesn't lunge after other dogs doesn't go at lunch after people.
It's fucking mellow.
It just chills out.
But if you leave it alone,
it like freaks,
you know,
or if it anticipates that you're leaving it alone,
it starts like shaking uncontrollably and it starts drooling,
which are all signs,
I guess,
that this separation anxiety.
So evidently it's this four week fucking process that I have to go through.
But I totally loved the dog now,
so I don't give a fuck.
I literally canceled gigs to make sure this dog is cool.
And um,
it's,
it's a long story.
If you want to know what you got to do is basically what I've learned is,
is there certain triggers that the dog has that sets it off to freaking out?
Like you grabbing your keys and here's the sound of your keys.
Or maybe you turn the shower on,
or your girlfriend starts blow drying her hair or whatever.
Just things like that starts at,
you know,
it starts looking at you.
Then you put your shoes on,
you put your coat on.
And all in all it associates that shit with is,
Oh fuck,
I'm being abandoned again.
And you know,
I don't fucking know.
I don't write the books.
I don't have the ability to actually know what a dog is thinking.
But I'm imagining,
considering that this dog was just left by the La River,
can you believe that someone didn't even bring it to the shelter?
They just opened their car door or whatever and just left it out there.
You know,
like,
I don't know what the fuck at eight kills me.
It kills me every time.
I think that someone would do that.
But,
um,
so I guess that that's where this dog's mind goes mentally.
So,
uh,
we have to fucking decondition you've got to figure out what it's an,
the very first trigger is,
and then you work your way through all of them and you just do one trigger,
like pick up your keys,
sorta walk around with them as you're giving it this food.
I don't even,
I just read the fucking book.
It's,
it's a long goddamn process,
but I'm going to work through it.
So that's basically what you're supposed to do in a nutshell.
I'm real.
And you know what I mean?
Do you ever just read something on the Internet and then you try to fucking talk
about it?
Like,
you know what you're talking about?
That's what that last couple of minutes was.
But it's,
it's,
you know,
I'm fucking,
I'm,
I'm learning about this stuff and I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm going to do what I gotta do.
But basically I had been held captive with this dog.
I've been with this fucking dog for the last,
uh,
five days in a row,
other than when I go out to do sets.
But then my girls here,
when we just make sure we don't leave it alone,
so it doesn't freak out as we learn how to diffuse.
It's problem.
Okay.
So last week I was asking people if they have any ideas because I went to put
the thing in a cage,
which was a stupid fucking thing to do.
I just didn't,
I was ignorant.
I didn't know.
I didn't know what the dog's problem was.
I didn't know how to introduce a cage to a dog who's gone through the stuff that
my dog's gone through.
So,
you know,
I made a rookie mistake,
so I was reaching out to my podcast listeners and a,
these are some of the emails.
I got a bill.
Uh,
I've always been in a household with dogs since I was born and I've never had
any of those fucking small female dogs like a Chihuahua.
I mean,
I had big male dogs,
German shepherds,
Husky labs,
that type of stuff.
And uh,
one of my dogs has broken out of his cage before.
However,
you must not know how to train a dog because my never fucked up the house even
when he was young.
Dogs are so rowdy and hard to handle when they are young,
they are hyper and they need lots of attention.
By the way,
you really shouldn't have a dog if someone can't be home with it most of the
day.
Now,
I don't know about you guys.
I'm stopping halfway through,
but that was just packed with information that I didn't know really.
I shouldn't have a dog if someone can't be home with it most of the day.
I had no idea.
You know,
I thought I could just get a dog,
stick them on the roof of my fucking apartment and leave for seven days.
I figured maybe it'll rain,
you know,
and they can just don't,
don't they store water in their bodies like fucking camels.
I have no idea what a fucking douchebag.
He's all ready a Douche bag and then he has the balls,
the fucking ego wrapped around his balls to write another paragraph of obvious
shit.
Here we go.
Everybody.
I've got a three year old out there.
Maybe they want to listen to the rest of this for this fucking information.
Here is what this fucking Einstein says.
The rest of this,
you have to give it affection.
It's like a baby.
She except you don't have to send it to college.
Now he didn't say that part.
All right.
Uh,
she just wants attention.
She needs to be walked and petted and played with everyday.
That's right.
Petted.
This is the guy who thinks I'm a fucking morning.
Um,
how often do you walk her and pet her and pet her daily?
Were you drunk when you type this?
You already said pet aid in the other thing.
Anyways,
he says,
guess what?
You do have to fucking build up the trust or the dog isn't going to obey you
as that.
That right there in a nutshell is how people give advice on the Internet.
Guess what?
Hey Fuck.
Head like that whole vibe.
It just blows my mind why someone can't be like,
Oh hey,
I got a dog.
This is the stuff I went through and this is kind of what I tried.
Hope it works every he's got,
everybody's got,
not everybody,
but so many people came at me like I couldn't believe it.
So anyways,
he says,
guess what?
You do have to fucking build up trust or the dog isn't going to obey you.
Really,
really?
I have no idea.
I thought I was like fucking Tarzan.
I could just start communicate or fucking doctor Doolittle.
What an asshole.
You're an asshole.
Douche bag and con to the week and I haven't even finished your fucking email.
All right,
I'm continuing.
Um,
alright.
What the fuck?
Why can't even get through this sentence?
Guess what your Blah Blah Blah.
And she's going to find every way she can to break loose when she's confined and
you're not home.
My lab is 13 years old,
but he still needs to play and be petted,
I think.
Is it petted?
It needs to be pet you dumb.
Fuck.
That's not even a word.
Hey,
fuck head.
Now I'm doing it.
I'm just pissed because you're coming at me like does she a cunt?
I just asked you for advice,
you know,
thank God you don't teach kids anyways.
Uh,
if yours is whimpering at night,
it's most likely she didn't get much interaction.
Feels lonely.
Three e's and fields.
By the way,
I don't think you should have a dog bill.
Really?
I don't think you should have a computer.
What do you think about that?
How about that?
Fuck head.
I don't think you should have a queue.
You shove a fucking computer screen,
but not a keyboard and maybe a secretary.
I learned nothing in that.
All right.
First of all,
Douche bag or the week.
Why would you think that you could even begin to analyze what is wrong with this
dog without ever meeting it?
You're basically superimposing the dogs you had in your life over this dog.
Did any of the dogs you have get left by a fucking river for God knows how many
fucking days now you know he's just going to make it up.
Well,
Yost job,
my Labrador was worth by biopharm phone.
Do dogs need attention?
Do you understand?
I mean,
I guess because I didn't explain it.
You've got to understand,
I've been giving this dog so much attention.
It's,
it's affecting my relationship with my girlfriend.
Okay?
She has all she could do to get me to cuddle with her,
but I have literally been late.
I can't walk to the fridge without laying down on the floor with that fucking
dog and telling her how awesome it is for like 20 minutes every time.
I'm not getting anything done.
A write,
you fucking moron.
I've had dogs.
I also grew up with dogs.
I was just asking for help.
All right?
You can't stop acting like everyone in my family.
Jesus Christ.
You know what?
I,
I feel so much better about my family.
Some of these fucking emails I didn't want to be,
I didn't want to be angry.
Look at this,
what this is doing to me.
All right,
here's the second Douche bag of the week he'll ever contest.
Which one of these two people do you think is a bigger douchebag this way or are
they both?
Cons.
All right,
here we go.
There's a second email.
First off,
I really enjoy your comedy and your Monday morning podcast when you don't target
out and post it on time.
That part doesn't even make sense.
So you enjoy when I don't tart out and post it on time,
I don't get,
Oh,
when I don't tart out,
when I'm not a moron,
and I posted on time.
Okay,
maybe that's me.
All right,
second.
So he starts off nice or she,
I don't even know who the fuck wrote this.
Second,
try not using a fucking cage.
A duh.
I swear to God and adult rock debt.
Second,
try not using a fucking cage.
A duh.
Now,
why would you think the reader at this point would remotely give a,
you could be telling me how to win $1 million in this paragraph.
The second you come at me,
this condescendingly I'm not,
I don't give a fuck what you have to say,
but for the sake of my listeners,
I'm going to read the rest of this.
All right?
You fucking,
I need a new cord for can't.
There's so many concerts week.
All right,
let's start over again with that sentence.
Second,
try not using a fucking cage.
A De,
as long as you keep small objects in and your trash away from the dogs reach,
you can get the dog to pass out.
Most of the time you're away.
Once again,
here's a guy who has no idea what I'm dealing with.
Any completely writes off cages.
You know,
all these people you see at the airport where the dogs in one of those fucking
cages and they don't have a problem with it because they introduced the cage in
a proper way rather than the stupid way that I did it at the pet store or I
tried to figure out if the dog could fit into it by pushing it by head first.
As I'm pushing its ass as it's using all its pit bull muscle on the linoleum to
be like,
Eh,
I don't feel like going in there.
You know,
whatever.
I'm not good with spatial relations.
I did what I had to do.
Um,
okay,
let's continue.
Um,
uh,
as we,
the first week of trying to figure out the new section,
who's a bigger douche bag.
Sorry,
let me read the rest of this year.
Um,
finding a proper dog toy is necessary but avoid anything that can be eaten and
salivated on dash raw heights.
Now there's almost some information.
So I know I don't need raw hides.
I don't know why he's a,
he hasn't really told me why,
but I guess I just avoid those.
Um,
this is like getting sex education in like the forties,
you know,
when no one could fucking talk about it.
This is brutal.
All right.
Instead of all the,
that time you wasted teaching the dog to be comfortable in an in comfortable
place and uncomfortable place.
He's talking about the cage.
You could have been teaching it to behave in the household.
Really?
Oh,
I had no idea.
It's not like I walked in into the fucking apartment and just shoved it into a
cage.
You fucking idiot.
I had it on the leash.
I walked at all around the house.
Everything was going great,
everything was going great.
And then it had some bet,
had bad experiences with the cages and then it won't go in the room where the
cage was because it had a bad experience in there.
Jesus,
fuck,
I know I'm sick of these dog whisperer.
People Watch fucking 10 episodes and then they think they,
they can like fucking put their hand on top of your dog and cure it.
I don't know,
not that you care,
but my friend of 10 years has had two pit bulls in a house area smaller than my
one bedroom apartment and it doesn't destroy anything that you don't allow it to
destroy for every failed attempt of taking a dog in a dog,
there is a flunky of an owner.
Evidently that's me.
You don't even have kids.
You can definitely do this bill.
See that's positive,
have patience and understanding and that dog will give you unconditional love
for many years.
All right.
You know this guy is like,
this is like a battered wife fucking email.
He starts off nice,
sucks me in for a software.
Really enjoy your comedy.
Monday morning podcasts.
I'm like,
yeah,
you have.
Really as I'm sticking my chin out,
then he gives me a fucking uppercut,
try not use in a fucking cage.
Uh,
Duh.
Right?
And then he trashes me,
basically alludes to the fact that I'm a flunky,
maybe a flunky owner.
I Dunno.
And then,
and then he starts stroking my head when I,
and I'm like,
you know what amount of this relationship,
I'm going back home to my father.
I don't need this anymore.
And then he says,
now they'll have patients and understanding the dark,
you know,
you look beautiful and your little Dickie shorts
anyways.
You know,
something,
you animal lovers,
you're out of your fucking minds.
That's all I can say.
You got more goddamn passion for animals than you do for losing your fucking
conveniences in this country.
You know what I mean?
They'll fucking stand there and continue to pay $15 for their first fucking bag.
Even though the price of gas has come down.
You can never get them to sign a fucking petition.
But Jesus Christ,
if somebody throws an errand frisbee and it hits a fucking shower in the side of
it's fucking leg,
there'll be hate.
There'll be fucking making software.
We have people with signs.
If I have,
if somebody from the goddamn animal shelter ever heard my last podcast,
I probably have protestors outside my next funnybone Gig.
So anyways,
I want to thank everyone who actually sent me advice trying to help me out.
Okay.
I'm not a bad dog owner.
I just didn't understand what the dog was going through.
Okay.
And it's,
you know,
it's head too.
It's had three really traumatic events since I've had it just out of my own
ignorance.
Okay.
I put it in two different cages because I didn't understand why it was clogging
up my apartment.
I just thought it was doing what dogs do,
you know.
And once again,
I didn't fucking decide to get a dog.
My girlfriend has brought this thing home.
So we had our lives to lead.
So that was a horrific experience.
And one day when we left,
we left a daughter,
our balcony open and this kills me to say this,
it walked out on the balcony and the wind blew the door shut and was stuck out
there for like 40 minutes.
And when we got there,
it was standing there trembling and drew,
it was fucking,
it was horrific.
And uh,
I,
you know,
I felt like I didn't deserve a dog.
Uh,
so since then,
no,
I take it for hikes every day.
It just to make you fucking dog lovers relax.
Okay.
I swear to God.
All right.
I just watched,
I was,
you know,
I'm actually doing this,
this podcast by the way,
on a Sunday evening here because I want to make sure I was able to edit that
thing on the front and do everything right.
So people on the east coast wouldn't have to wait till the end of the fucking
day to listen to this thing.
But um,
you know,
I want to go play drums.
I wanted to play drums for three fucking days,
but I refuse to leave this dog alone.
I refuse for this dog to have another bad experience due to me on my watch.
So all you guys can relax and if you want to give me advice,
give me advice.
But I don't need advice that begins with hey shit,
Dick,
or whatever that you know,
cause that really as you can tell it all it does is fucking annoying me,
you know,
and I combined that,
I thought I had a great week.
You know,
I gave you guys a podcast.
I put a new video up on my myspace page and on my youtube page,
by the way,
which I don't have the fucking name for,
I forget the name of it,
but a,
I put it up there.
I put up like fucking 30 new photos.
What else did I do?
So that was a video.
I gave you a podcast,
I gave you new pictures and I had been,
I blogged all week for the NHL.
You know,
by the way,
congratulations to the Carolina hurricanes.
He has sons of bitches a best for checking.
I've,
I've seen on a hockey team and a long fucking time.
You guys were phenomenal.
You deserve to wear it and a good lucks against the penguins.
You sons of bitches and uh,
anybody who took my blog seriously,
uh,
you can go fuck yourself because,
it says in the thing that I'm a comedian,
so if you take my job seriously,
I,
I can't,
I can't help you,
you know?
You know what I mean?
I,
I'm trying to fucking come up with an analogy here.
You know,
I don't expect the Weatherman to be funny,
you know,
and I don't expect the comedian to be seriously serious.
So if they write something fucked up that obviously they're joking.
So all those references I made you guys not having shoes and
in play and washboards and tubs in the stands and fucking,
you know,
not being real hockey fans cause you're from down south.
If you took any of that seriously,
then you really are the moron that I was jokingly saying that you were.
Okay.
You know why I was referring to you as the Hartford whalers.
All right.
I was having fun.
I was just talking shit.
You know,
unless I say it about Montreal Canadien fans,
that's the only time I mean it,
you know,
but even then I'll give it,
they get a beautiful city with gorgeous women.
Um,
all right,
so there you go.
So onto the podcast here and I'm basically going to be reading a bunch of shit
that I read last week but wasn't able to,
uh,
to update.
Uh,
why the fuck am I,
uh,
what are we going to do here?
What am I get to?
Uh,
some of the things that I asked him,
I,
my podcast a couple of weeks ago,
I had mentioned a couple of weeks ago that I was a,
I was flying from New York to a back out here to la at the height of the swine
flu epidemic.
No,
but that one,
you know,
the devastation,
bring out your dead,
you know,
nothing fucking happened.
But anyways,
I get on the plane or I'm waiting to get on the plane.
I sit in the terminal and I noticed that,
you know,
there's a couple of hundred people there waiting to get on the plane and 15
people are wearing those surgical masks and a all 15 were Asian and there was no
nobody else if any race was wearing the mass.
So I was like,
what the fuck?
Why are they the only ones wearing mass?
And somebody actually sent me an interesting observation,
I don't know if this is true or not,
but they said,
uh,
hey bill,
you asked about the agents wearing the mass.
I may have an answer.
As a person says,
I was over in Japan last year and notice that I would see people wearing those
masks everywhere I went.
So I asked a buddy of mine who lives there and he said that because everyone is
so jam packed up to their eyeballs and people basically they in close proximity,
uh,
they were there,
they were mess because uh,
they wear them.
Um,
what does it say?
I just lost my place.
They wear them even when they just have a cold.
I'm assuming it's just a way of life to where the mass,
when you're sick or something,
hope this helps.
So I guess over there everybody's so jam packed than I imagined a co,
uh,
the common cold would spread like wildfire.
So they put those things on,
I guess that kind of makes sense.
What does that mean?
All 15 of them had had the common cold or they all had the bird flu,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
Or maybe they're more educated evidentaly their technology's better over there
somehow what happened to America.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
We were the shit,
we still out of this shit.
We're just a bunch of fucking people now sitting around the cubicles,
you know.
Do you guys see some of the pictures of the great American cars that I put up
there?
Just,
you know,
I only put up like three,
I want to put up a bunch more.
But uh,
that period,
man,
I'm telling you from the 1940s,
right through the 60s,
you know,
okay.
Where it was just the heyday of American cars and the steel industry and all
that type of shit.
We had a fuck what happened?
You know,
what happened at where we can't,
well we don't make the best cell phone.
We would,
that should really bother us,
shouldn't it?
What?
I would just fucking,
I dunno,
it's really bug.
It's really bothering me.
So I dunno.
I'm really don't have anything to say about it.
But if you listen to these last fucking,
if you listened to that pathetic attempt at social commentary,
maybe you understand why we can't make a good cell phone or the best one out
there.
And uh,
speaking of that,
um,
let's talk about computer stuff.
You know,
this is the new segment.
I wish I had a little bit of theme music out there.
You know,
if somebody could write me some,
uh,
you're going to learn something,
theme music and send it as an MP three.
I'll play it for this part because this is a new segment here where,
um,
you guys are basically teaching me how not to be a moron with my,
uh,
with my computer.
And this is something last week,
you know,
I was bitching about how people always send me these emails and the font is
really small and hour.
I already suck at reading out loud if you haven't noticed yet.
So I was wishing that people would send it bigger.
So someone goes,
well actually this is what you can do if somebody sends us an email and you
can't really read it because the fonts too small,
all you have to do is hit the apple command button and the uh,
the plus side,
like you know,
two plus two and you can make the,
you can make the font get bigger or the apple and the minus sign and you can
make it gets smaller and it even works on the Internet,
you know,
for like old people,
did it,
trying to find tube eight.
Okay.
You don't try to find two girls one cup.
And I could,
she went to show like good food.
So they hit apple fucking plus.
Wow.
How big old people's keyboards.
You ever seen that?
Like ever see like old people's phones?
And like the fucking,
it's like literally the number pad is as big as like a toddler's hopscotch,
fucking bored,
you know,
you have a seat,
some shit like that.
They just really scares you.
You know,
dying doesn't really scare me because I really have this belief.
Like I really believe in that whole thing that like death is a release and uh,
I'm looking forward to becoming a fossil fuel.
You know,
like I don't really need to uh,
continue this,
you know,
I just,
I think
okay,
you know,
live in light living.
If you live a full life,
that's enough.
That should be enough.
And then I,
then I should just become a,
yeah,
a fuel.
Can't think of anything.
I don't know.
Moon dust,
whatever the fuck,
you know,
just become part of some shit that other things that are alive.
Look at what do I got to keep living.
Do you realize the fucking how?
Uh,
Ego maniacal that is
okay
to feel that you like God like that you just continue living in this other
state.
I don't understand that.
It's really,
it's either that or you just can't wrap your head around.
Not existing,
which I definitely can't fucking do.
But the beauty of not existing as you don't exist,
so you can't sit there thinking like,
fuck,
I don't exist any more.
You just don't exist.
That's it.
You know,
God,
I wish I was deep.
That was pathetic.
Just skimming the surface of a bunch of cool shit.
And I just have nothing to say because I don't read.
Um,
anyways,
but you ever see that shit?
You ever see some shit where uh,
it just reminds you of like,
you know,
I guess maybe to enjoy living.
I was in a hardware store and no,
I wasn't.
I was in cvs and I saw a booster seat for the toilet
and I was just like,
wow.
You know,
like that,
that is an option.
Like that could possibly happen to me where I could get so fucking old that I
have the ability to lower myself down onto a regulation height,
toilet seat.
But I lacked the quad strength to get my in my legs,
to get myself back up.
You know?
Gee,
I he didn't.
Well,
how do you figure that?
Does that just happen?
One day you sit down and then you just can't fucking get up again and then you
just have to fucking,
what do you do?
You got to fucking just sort of lean over to one side and fall off the toilet.
Hope there's not a vanity there and then you just lay in there on the tiles.
You balls is still on the toilet water.
See what I'm saying?
People,
this is my inspirational speech.
She got to live life.
You got to live life.
Get a fucking dog.
I'm telling you,
you're as such shutdown emotional psychopath.
I cannot tell you how much having a dog has helped me in fucking two weeks.
I have in this thing.
I absolutely unconditionally fucking love this dog.
I absolutely fucking love this dog.
And uh,
I uh,
to the point and take it and you know,
in the exact thing that I was running from the reason why I never got a dog,
like the responsibility of having one and having a walk the fucking thing and
give it water.
And if it takes a shit,
I got to pick it up in a fritos bag,
you know,
and act like I'm walking to my trash barrel when I'm really going to my
neighbors,
you know,
going through all that bullshit.
That's the thing I think I loved the most.
I actually like that I have a reason to walk away from having fucking four
Scotches,
you know?
Now I only have three,
you know,
and then I come home half in the bag and I started screaming at the dog about my
childhood.
You know,
it's a great thing.
I don't see,
I don't scream at him like it's his fault.
I just yell at it about my childhood,
you know?
No,
I don't do that shit.
I just like getting you animal lovers up in a fucking,
get your panties in a bunch.
Do you really do?
It's just a job.
It doesn't understand.
Oh
no,
but it's,
it's,
it's been,
it's been a great thing to the point.
I'm literally,
I took it to the beach today and uh,
it's fucking hilarious.
Took it down to the water and this thing is so god damn like muscular.
It's ridiculous.
Like you remember those that you don't really ever see pumping iron.
Did you ever see that when those guys that you know that that dead fucking the
hulk Hogan Flex where they,
I don't know how to do it.
How the fuck to you without visually all right,
you bring it up,
right?
Like in the wrestler,
bring it up.
Remember that show off the v and then you bring it back down and you got your
two fists meeting right above your fucking pubes that shot.
Right.
You know,
fucking all the muscles papa.
That's what this fucking dog looks like when it's running.
And it was absolutely terrified of the water and the ocean.
You know,
like I was trying to get it to go out where it was just above its neck,
you know,
you know where it's paws weren't touching the ground.
The tide was really strong and shit.
So it was kind of,
but we kind of offsetting each other like counterbalance and each other with
like the weight of the dog and me.
You know,
a couple of times like the waves like washing over and he's doing like
somersaults and shit and uh,
the thing got so far
fucking scared.
I'm looking at it like,
dude,
you're a pit bull.
This is pathetic.
We're in Venice beach.
People are watching,
you know,
you know what's funny is people who are really into animals actually just
believe that fucking story.
They actually,
I went out into the ocean with the fucking dog.
I've,
I'm terrified of the fucking ocean.
Don't you guys listen to my act?
How much you seen any of my past specials?
I am absolutely fucking terrified of the ocean.
I will not go in it younger way.
I'll go in and if my boat sinks,
okay or if I'm on fire.
And even then,
even then,
then what the fuck is that?
Even then I'll just stay in the shadow of shallow water.
Can't fucking talk.
All of a sudden
I used to do a bit in my act,
right?
Uh,
I love how I just throw these jokes out cause I'm never going to put them on
albums or anything like that.
I used to do this bit in my act where I was talking about being terrified of the
ocean.
You know,
cause I'm scared of sharks stare.
I'm scared of getting eaten alive and drowning at the same time,
you know,
combining,
like split and aces in a bad way,
like horrific deaths,
you know.
So this guy one time,
this is the joke,
right?
He used to,
he,
this guy says to me,
trying to make me more relaxed.
Wait a minute,
is my phone ringing?
Sorry.
Breaking my balls at the Celtics last.
Oh,
since Joe to Rosa.
He doesn't give a shit.
He doesn't,
you guys want to hear?
Oh,
I got my first phone and call Joe to Rosa.
Hang on a second.
I'll put them on speaker.
Joe De Rosa.
Joe.
Hey Dude.
Hey.
Hey,
shut up.
I'm doing my podcast right now.
Yeah,
I got you on speaker.
So don't say anything fucked up.
You're going to be on my podcast.
Joe Derosa from the uninformed show everybody
some time now with my good friend Scott here.
And,
uh,
I kept,
I kept talking about that drum clip where the guy played like the 64th notes
was,
what is that guy's name?
I gotta show it to them.
Oh,
Joe.
Joe Mayor.
Yeah.
Joe Joe Mayer.
John Mayer took Joe.
Joe.
Okay.
Uh,
no,
I,
yeah,
I don't mind.
I Dunno.
Gelato.
Listened to John Mayer.
Joe,
Joe Mayor.
Like,
like Brittany Spears now.
Um,
I think it's either within,
yeah,
just,
just look it up.
You'll find it.
Just write Jo Jo Mayor Bass Drum and uh,
just,
just watch what he does.
All right.
I'm going to watch what he does and your fans.
I love all of you.
And keep listening to the bill.
Bernbach cash.
Hey Joe,
why don't you hire your next Gig?
Get fucking drunk.
I'll be in Indianapolis this weekend at crackers.
Crackers.
Yes.
If you come see me and I appreciate it.
Okay.
All right.
Joseph,
will you have a good night of drinking?
I'll talk to you later.
Thank you,
Bill.
That's uninformed shoulder rose everybody.
And I completely forgot what the fuck I was talking about.
Oh,
I was talking to him.
I was going to do that first joke.
Okay.
See that?
You see what he's doing?
He's just drinking.
He's out drinking on a Sunday night.
Why you guys all don't become comedians?
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Earthquake,
earthquake,
earthquake.
Fuck.
Hang on,
hang on,
hang on.
Oh,
I was a little one.
That was a little one.
Okay.
How about that?
A phone in,
in a fucking earthquake and a fucking MP.
Three at the beginning is this is the best God damn podcast ever.
Jesus Christ.
Is that scary?
Huh?
So for,
you know what you do when the earthquake,
you just,
you just sort of stand there and you put your fucking hands out.
Like you could somehow stop the energy.
You know,
like all of a sudden you're a,
I dunno,
some superhero,
they knows how to stop the fuck.
That's what I did.
I said,
okay.
Okay.
Normally I would actually run into the door jamb.
Wait a fucking minute.
Wait a minute.
I got a dog.
Okay.
Hey cleo.
Aren't you supposed to give me a warning about that shit?
I thought you fucking dogs knew stuff about that.
We just just proved them fucking meth right there.
Hang on a second.
I got to make sure my dogs are right.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ready?
Alright.
Get shown.
All right.
The dog's dog show is probably just a truck driving by.
I'm such a fan.
All right.
Anyways,
let's get back to as,
wow,
this is really okay.
You know what's funny?
Look at me working on my memory.
Thank you everybody for all your tips out there that I can't remember what the
fuck they were and I haven't even used them.
I'm lying,
but I'm going to use them.
I'm going to use them.
What does it Pictionary?
What the fuck am I supposed to use?
Um,
I'm actually,
I actually remember what I was talking about.
MMM.
The fuck fuckers I know.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I was still doing one.
Uh,
one of my,
one of my jokes I used to do,
but seven,
eight years ago,
if you saw me down the comedy cellar,
you might recognize this one goes a little something like this.
Uh,
what was I talking?
Oh yeah,
this how this guy was trying to get me to not be freaked out about going into
the ocean and sharks.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
well,
you know some bill,
a lot of people don't realize this,
but out 90% of shark attacks actually happened in the shallow water.
And My punchline was like,
yeah,
that's where the people are.
It's called the beach.
Stupid.
Right?
Stupid little attitude.
I wore a leather jacket.
I was dangerous back then.
What the fuck was the tat tagged to that?
I literally have to go back to the beginning to remember.
Yeah.
It's where the people are.
It's called the beach.
Stupid.
You know,
it's like to some guy goes,
yeah,
let's do you know,
I used to mind swimming.
Let's go out.
Let's go to Europe.
You fucking pussies.
That was the joke.
Oh,
and the people,
they would laugh,
they would laugh and I would get myself a free falafel.
That's what I would do when I worked at the comedy cellar.
You do food spots,
food spots back in the day,
which meant you literally were working for food.
That's how much fun my fucking job is.
I used to drive from Boston all the way down to New York City and I used to sign
up for the late night at the comedy cellar.
Uh,
and late night was at uh,
between one and two in the morning or two 30 in the morning and back then you
would simply sign up $9.
A lot of young comics right now I think in that,
that was really easy and they're actually right because now they make them
fucking,
they got to do pre shows and they got to bring 20 fucking people and blow
somebody.
It's,
it's,
they got a bark outside standing with flyers as brutal back back in the day,
you'd just go down and you'd sign up.
But I would drive three and a half hours down,
sign up three and a half hours back.
I knew I had to do that one too.
That was how fucking dumb I was.
This is my big way that I was going to get in,
in like at [inaudible] in New York or whatever.
Just my whole way,
like I had to take baby steps when I went to New York because I was so
intimidated when I went down to New York because all I had performed two was a
bunch of angry white dudes in Boston and I wasn't angry white dude.
I fucking grew up around angry white dude.
So it was,
no,
it wasn't a problem.
Then when I went down in New York,
everybody's there.
There was,
he don't Puerto Ricans,
black people,
fucking Puerto Ricans.
Alright,
blanked out whatever.
There's a bunch of other people there,
right?
Oh wait a second.
I saw a do rag.
I'd get like,
I'd feel myself.
I literally just,
I get back on my heels and then there's nothing worse.
Bobbing sucks.
But when you bomb because you,
you were a fucking pussy.
That's the worst kind of bombing.
If you stand there right in your fucking given it right back to them and they're
just giving you shit and you'll lose.
But at least you told him to go fuck themselves.
There's this something,
it's still sucks.
I'm not going to lie.
It's still like a nice fucking liver shot.
But I'm telling you,
it's,
it hurts so much more when you're,
when you act like ned Beatty.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
what am I doing?
What am I doing here?
Well,
let's,
how far into this podcast out we can,
we had phone calls.
We've had fucking earthquakes.
I talked to my dog.
All right.
With 39 minutes in,
um,
oh,
coming up this week.
Let's,
let's for once,
let me hype.
Uh,
let me hyper.
What the fuck I got going on?
I'm going to be at the Improv out here in a Hollywood,
California.
I know a lot of people out,
uh,
out West are always asking me,
when are you going to be forming in la?
Well,
there you go.
Your sons a bitches.
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the Improv on Melrose.
Uh,
uh,
May 22nd and May 23rd.
That's a Friday and a Saturday.
Fridays at eight o'clock and Saturday two shows seven 30 and nine 30.
And I'm be breaking on a bunch of new material and we talking about my dog and
what a fucking moron I am.
I don't know what I'm going to say.
Let them emerging.
It's going to be hilarious.
Least I'm hoping it is.
And uh,
maybe that's what I'll do.
Maybe I'll just become that guy who fucking,
uh,
that's all right.
You know,
that's going to be a next career move.
I'm just gonna just talk about dogs and be that guy.
You know the dog guy,
he just talks about dogs.
Oh yes.
I saw that guy.
That's the best,
the quickest way to blow up.
You know,
I saw the other day that there was a,
uh,
you know,
and I,
I don't,
I don't begrudge anybody who sells tickets here.
Let me preface it with that.
But I saw that there was a ventriloquist who was booked to play in like this
basketball arena,
like a professional basketball or mean like where the fucking Atlanta Hawks play
or some shit.
All right.
And God bless that guy.
He deserves every fucking dime he gets.
But this is the question I have for you.
What kind of a fucking moron sits in the upper deck of a Goddamn arena to watch
your fucking ventriloquist
in a salmon?
I'm saying.
I mean,
what?
What,
what do you say on the car ride home?
You couldn't get it.
I couldn't even,
I couldn't even see his lips move.
Yeah.
Even when he was talking,
you couldn't see it.
You're dumb cunt.
You fucking 20 rows away.
Okay.
It was,
I didn't vote.
I was amazed in the way he could throw his voice.
It was almost like they had invented some sort of apparatus that amplified what
he was saying because it was so loud and it was so far away and yet I couldn't
see his lips moving.
Can you imagine being that dumb?
How much fun you have?
Like how good does ice cream taste when you're that fucking stupid?
You could have vanilla ice cream and enjoy a bowl of that.
Just having the time of your life too dumb to stop eating it.
Just wondering why you keep getting headaches.
Oh,
great.
Another untimely headache.
Just when I was going to enjoy the rest of this ice cream.
Why do these untimely headaches always have to come when I'm enjoying what I
love to do.
Most eating a whole bowl of vanilla ice cream
dot.
That would be great just to be there.
Fucking stupid,
you know,
it's stupid.
I've talked about this before.
You know,
that stupid way.
Your fucking mouth is open.
Even when you're not talking.
You know those people and just sit there and for some reason their tongue never
dries out.
Even a bulldog,
that tip of its tongue will dry out after a while,
but morons that,
I don't know what it is,
that tongue never did,
never dries out.
So you've got to just sit there and look at it.
You know,
it's annoying.
If it was dried out,
it at least make you feel good that there was suffering.
All right,
that was a tangent.
Um,
let's get back to the podcast here.
all right.
There was actually some great questions here.
This is why I actually saved these.
Um,
this is a great,
if you guys want to have a,
uh,
if you want to have a blueprint for a great question.
I am actually,
you know,
I got to tell you,
you guys have really stepped up and general,
I'm going to give you all a pat on the back.
You guys are really,
you're writing really funny shit in there.
They're great questions.
Like this one here.
Listen to this question,
Bill.
If you were a serial killer,
how would you kill your victims and what would be your serial killer name?
Uh,
for my job,
I have a lot of time to think about stuff.
And I was listening to your story about the Green River killer and it got me to
thinking if I was a serial killer,
how would I do it?
He's alluding to my podcast a couple of weeks ago.
I was talking about how they always give like serial killers nicknames,
like they're playing in the fucking Rose Bowl,
you know?
Uh,
so anyways,
so,
so he actually action.
And you know what,
that's what I did last week.
That's what the fuck I did.
I looked up a bunch of serial killer nicknames.
You know,
I noticed a lot of guys had a great nicknames,
but there was actually a surprising amount of female serial killers,
but not enough of them got cool nicknames except for this one lady who was known
as the giggling grandmother and a,
I can't remember it was a couple of weeks ago,
but she literally killed like four husbands,
both her sisters,
a second cousin or whatever.
And they finally,
you know,
figured out what the fuck was going on.
The amount of Shit you could get away with back in the day,
you know,
nowadays you got to kill like 22 complete strangers back in the day before they
knew how to dust for fingerprints and they didn't have all this fucking DNA
investigation.
You could literally kill everybody at work.
You know,
you work with 40 people in 40 weekends in a row,
somebody could be disappearing and you could literally just keep shrugging your
shoulders going,
ah,
I don't know either.
I mean,
yeah,
what are the odds?
Um,
so anyways,
when they finally picked up this old lady and they interrogated her,
I guess she would just laugh when they were,
did you kill him?
And she would just sort of laugh and say,
yeah,
I did.
And they tell if she was just trying to mask her embarrassment or if she was
just that shut down or whatever.
But she got the nickname,
the giggling grandmother.
That's a great one.
The giggling grandma literations grandmother,
she supposed to be making cookies and she's out killing people.
Gives you a chill.
It's fucking beautiful.
So anyways,
let's get back to this.
So this guy says he feats sat around thinking about it at work and a okay,
here's his deal.
He said,
not to sound too crazy,
but I did give it to some give,
did give it some thought as how I would kill somebody.
He said,
I figured I would use a stick I found in the forest and sharpen it,
use it and then burn the evidence.
I would be the caveman killer.
Dude.
I got to tell you,
that's just fucking great.
That's just really well thought out.
How fucking awesome is that all these guys for years in the mob,
you know,
they tape up the gun with duct tape and then they shoot the dude and then they
throw it in the fucking river and then some fucking nerd who never gets any
pussy.
Who's got time to use a metal detector at the bottom of the river,
finds the fucking thing.
And next thing you know,
you get busted at your third year fucking high school graduation,
right?
It happens all the time.
This is perfect.
It's perfect.
If you kill somebody,
you don't even know what the sharpened stick.
You burn the fucking stick.
This is so good.
I don't even want to fucking,
I don't even want to like,
like,
like talk about it.
I'm afraid I'm giving somebody a great idea.
So let's get to me.
How would I do it and what my serial killer name would be?
Um,
well if you know me,
um,
I'm a big fan of yesteryear.
I'm not looking forward to the future.
So I would go old school,
you know,
I would go old school.
I try to bring back the sickle,
you know,
I would use is sickle and uh,
and I would definitely get into the placement of the body.
Okay.
Well just be me because I learned from a cop that the more people you involve in
a crime,
the higher chance you have of getting caught because somebody is going to be
that fucking moron.
Like that kid.
I mean that fucking kid in,
uh,
was it Saturday night fever when he doesn't jump in on the fight?
Where will you guys,
oh,
I was looking for you.
There's always one of those guys,
you know,
they just start crying and I was with this guy bill,
he's fucking work in the fucking Improv next weekend.
Um,
so I would definitely do it alone and I would bring back the sickle.
I would wear the hood and I would do all that type and I wouldn't wear the hood.
It just make me all sweaty.
I'm going to kill him.
Who cares what they see my face.
And basically what I would do is I would just fucking chop their heads off and I
would leave the head in their bed and I'd leave their body in the bathtub and I
would be known as the,
uh,
bed bath and be header
and I can,
I just apologize for that.
I really knew that that was going to stink as though as I was starting to say
it,
I knew that that was going to be awful.
But I dunno,
I was just,
I was trying to fucking,
I hate corporations and if there was just a way that you could go around killing
people and to have it kind of sound like best buy or bed bath and beyond just so
some fucking douchebag would have to actually stand behind a podium and actually
read some letter of detraction going,
we don't condone,
we here at bed,
bath and beyond,
do not condone what the bed bath and be header does.
We don't condone,
um,
even just the Celtic people,
once again,
we are bed bath and beyond.
We,
there's no beheading that happens here.
And,
um,
I know he's still on the loose,
but I think it's safe to say that he does not work for us and we are cooperating
with the local authorities,
have answered all their questions and that's all we have to say on the matter.
And we would just like to get back to selling pillowcases,
you know,
just to make them fucking do that.
Eric Diego,
this is a podcast for the week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Lot of thrills,
lot of spills are the alert quake.
Little,
a little,
a little bit of everything.
I hope I was able to edit that MP three in the front of this because I recorded
this fucking thing first.
You know,
so,
uh,
that's it.
Please come out and see me at the,
uh,
the Improv this week and I'm trying to put together none that another Ra Monday
show up at the punchline in San Francisco.
I had so much fun last March doing that.
And uh,
that's what I got going on.
congratulations to the people down there in Orlando.
Uh,
you got a great basketball team,
you'd beat my Celtics.
Congratulations to you guys.
You know you've got something better to do then fucking put steel balls
underneath your fucking pickup truck and drive over to Epcot center,
you know,
or have a wild weekend down there in Tampa.
Huh?
You know,
or just sit around watching your mullets grow.
you got,
you go into the fucking eastern conference finals.
Who Do you guys like?
Who Do you like?
I got to tell you,
I'm rooting for the fucking nuggets and I'm living out here in la.
I really,
you know,
I don't hate,
I don't hate Laker fans cause it's like they live here,
so obviously they're fucking in the Lakers.
But what I do hate is how they're acting like they're anywhere near the amount
of championships at the Celtics have.
It's like,
dude,
you have nine.
The Los Angeles Lakers have nine championships.
Okay,
stop with this.
14 the Minneapolis Lakers one five.
Okay.
Your,
your,
your franchise has one 14 I'll give you that.
If you take two cities and you glue them together,
they have won,
you've won three less championships,
then the one city of Boston has won.
Don't have a fucking,
forget that.
All right.
Because if the Lakers ever moved to fucking Las Vegas and they won a
championship,
how would you think of some Douche bag?
And Vegas was like,
yeah,
we got 15 bitches.
It's like,
no you don't.
No.
You know you got one,
you got one.
All right.
See you fuckers.
You're still in single digits and you're going to lose to the nuggets.
At least I hope you do.
I hope you don't show up.
Hope.
You know.
I don't know why the Lakers aren't showing up.
This is easy for them.
Kevin,
Garnett,
south,
Bam.
It's wide open.
You're good to go.
The Cavaliers do not have enough guys on their team to beat you guys.
The nuggets don't have enough guys.
But you know what?
The nuggets and the Cavaliers have that the Lakers don't have.
They have heart.
They got fucking heart.
I'm telling you,
the lady who the fuck takes,
who takes games off in the playoffs?
Who does that?
You know,
does that the fucking Los Angeles Lakers.
It's almost like this.
So fucking good.
They just stay.
Ah,
let's fuck around.
I Dunno.
I don't fuck it.
No,
I'm just,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm bummed my team lost.
But you know something.
The can somebody in the NBA just called traveling?
I don't give a fuck.
Even if it's on my own.
I,
so I so fucking,
oh,
what's his face there tonight?
Fuck.
Am I trying to think.
I'm already thinking.
I,
they just suck with names.
Just pause,
Bill.
Think that Ray Lewis,
he plays for the fucking,
yeah.
Ray Allen.
Jesus Christ.
I'm getting old here.
I went and seen how ray Allen literally catches a ball.
He runs three steps,
clearly runs three steps,
and it takes a three pointer and hits it.
The Mana Times.
I just sit there and scream traveling as I watch an NBA game is that it's
ridiculous.
He know.
Ridiculous as I continue this podcast,
even though it was over.
It's over.
All right.
You guys get on with your lives,
your lives,
your lives.
What a fucking moron.
Alright,
you guys have a good week.
God bless.
Mm.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].